today you'll learn the basics of CSS
grid by building three different grid
layouts from scratch the first example
is a responsive 12 column grid it
replaces most of the use cases that
you'd find in a grid system like Twitter
bootstrap but it does so with only three
lines of code and removes the need for
all this crazy markup from your HTML
next we'll build a responsive photo
gallery and third we'll build an
explicit grid that has this fancy
staggered intro animation by the end of
this video you should know enough about
grid to start putting it to use in your
own projects if you're new here like it
subscribe and feel free to grab your
mouse the keyboard to code along with us
when you start just have a good feeling
and be happy and in love with life in
the world and sit down and begin playing
I'd like to start off by sharing my own
experience with grid because on fire
ship i/o I was previously using a
flexbox based system like you would find
in bootstrap and many other CSS
frameworks now there's nothing wrong
with using a third-party solution but
when you use grid you don't have to add
any additional CSS to your bundle size
the grid system just works natively in
the browser but the much more important
benefit was how much it simplified the
code base my HTML markup had a bunch of
columns each with its own collection of
classes to make that call and responsive
after moving to CSS grid I was able to
remove all these classes and implement
my own grid system with just three lines
of code and on top of that beautiful
designs that you would normally only
find in a magazine are much easier to
implement with grid because the system
itself is inspired by print based grids
now I should warn you that grid is
pretty weird to learn at first so let's
jump into some examples and understand
what every line of code is doing you can
follow along by opening your editor and
creating an HTML and CSS file or you can
clone the project from github and you'll
see that each grid is broken down into
its own HTML and CSS files this first
grid we're building is basically an
infinite set of responsive columns and
that's really useful if you have
something like a feed of cards like the
lesson feed on fire ship IO and a grid
like this will also replace many of the
use cases for something like Twitter
bootstrap grid go ahead and open an HTML
file in BS code then start typing HTML
to autocomplete the boilerplate code
next I'm going to go into the head of
the document add a style tag and an
import our base CSS as well as our basic
grid for this example the base CSS file
is just something that I'm going to
share across all the examples if we open
that file you'll notice that it has a
class that defines a flexbox that aligns
its content in the center
none of this code is actually required
for your grid to work it's just there to
make things look nice so feel free to
copy it from the main repo now going
back to our HTML we'll go into the body
and set up a section that will serve as
our main grid container then all of the
immediate children inside of this
container are known as grid items now
for this demo I'm adding 12 children to
the grid but I'm assuming the content
inside the grid is dynamic meaning we
might have three items in there 50 items
or whatever so what we need is an
implicit grid that can figure out the
right number of columns and rows based
on the content size and the viewport
size the first step is to set display
grid on the container and you'll notice
right now everything is just stacked up
in a single column let's start by giving
our children a little bit of spacing we
can do that with the gap property
instead of setting margins on the
children that will guarantee that we
always have one REM of spacing between
the items both horizontally and
vertically now one way to create columns
is to use the grid template columns
property let's start by creating an
explicit grid or a grid that has all of
its columns defined in advance now since
we're talking about columns think about
the width of the grid 1fr or one
fractional unit represents one part of
the available space currently we have
one column so when fo r is a hundred
percent of the available space we can
add another column by simply adding
another F our unit and now one fr equals
fifty percent of the available space and
we can keep doing this for as many
columns as we need or in our case twelve
columns the end result is an explicit
grid that always has twelve columns but
there's a few problems here first of all
this grid is not responsive and this
code is really ugly
fortunately CSS grid has a helper
function called repeat instead of
writing out each column manually we can
simply call repeat twelve and then pass
in the unit that we want to repeat this
code is identical to the code above but
much more concise and readable now
currently in the demo each column is too
thin let's look at how we can set a
minimum width of 240 pixels we'll try
again by repeating twelve columns but
this time use the min/max function this
is like saying make sure my columns
don't go below 240 pixels and width but
allow them to expand as big as one
fractional unit will allow what you'll
notice is that our cards are no longer
too skinny but we now have another
problem they're overflowing on the
horizontal axis so the question becomes
how do we make these columns break down
into additional rows when there's no
longer available space the answer is by
creating an implicit grid when we call
repeat instead of repeating twelve times
we'll repeat with autofit and then use
these same mid max value as before
what autofit does is tell grid to
calculate the number of rows and columns
on the fly and now you can see that we
have a truly responsive grid it only
took three lines of code and no
additional markup or classes in our HTML
it's worth noting that there's also an
autofill option the difference is subtle
but important notice here in the demo
how the top autofill option is going to
create additional columns when there
becomes additional space but autofit on
the bottom will expand its children to
take up all of the available space now
when you're working with grid and things
aren't going the way you expect open up
Firefox dev tools it has a really good
grid and flexbox inspector and you can
see here how it allows me to visualize
the lines and tracks on the grid now
it's time to move on to example number
two a responsive mosaic photo gallery
what you'll notice about this example is
that some of the photos are bigger some
are taller and some are wider and they
also reposition themselves gracefully
when the viewport size changes let's
start by going into the HTML and setting
up a grid container inside the container
we have 12 divs like we did in the
previous example but each div has a
photo URL as its background and by the
way these are free to use photos from
unsplash now if we go into the CSS will
use the code from the previous example
as our starting point but you'll notice
the rows in the grid are very short
that's because they're being
automatically sized to the text content
in the children now when you have an
implicit grid like this it can be useful
to set the size of the row if we want
all of our rows to be exactly 240 pixels
tall we can set the grid Auto rows
property to that value and now each
automatically created row will be fixed
to that height now our goal is to change
the sizing of individual grid items
let's create a class called card tall
any item with this class should span
across multiple rows vertically we can
do that with the grid row property and
then span to will tell it to span across
two rows from its starting position we
can use a slash to also specify its
ending point which in this case can be
figured out automatically by the grid
algorithm so the grid Row property is
like saying start here / end here it
makes more sense when you look at your
grid in Firefox
display the gridline numbers if we look
at the first photo you can see it starts
at column 1 Row 1 then ends at column 2
row 2 if we want to make this photo
taller we can do so explicitly with the
grid row property like saying start at
horizontal line 1 and end horizontal
line 4 and now you can see that photo
spans across 3 rows and everything else
was repositioned accordingly but since
we don't want to use the line numbers
explicitly will use span 2 to say start
wherever span 2 rows and then
automatically end wherever so that's how
we can make an item taller if we want to
make an item wider we can use the grid
column property and we can implement it
with the exact same value and now we can
go into our HTML and start applying
these classes to the items the end
result is a response to photo gallery
but there is one slight problem at
smaller sizes spanning two grid lines
doesn't work very well
notice how the items on the right are
way too skinny we can easily fix this by
wrapping our classes in a media query
this means the classes will do nothing
on smaller screen sizes and will only be
applied if the min width is greater than
600 pixels in the viewport and now
things will look much better on small
devices and that brings us to grid
number 3 it has this intro animation and
notice how each grid item comes in
clockwise until it gets to the center
you'll also notice the color changes as
it's being animated in and the middle
columns are responsive based on the
viewport size now again we have the same
basic HTML structure just a bunch of
divs inside a grid we'll set the display
to grid give it a gap but this time
we're going to create an explicit grid
using grid template areas this is a
really cool property that allows you to
create an explicit grid by giving names
to the different areas in the grid
notice how we have the letter a in the
top left and if we follow that clockwise
it goes all the way to L and then in the
middle we're actually using emojis to
represent the main content and a shout
out to Paul Newton who commented on the
last video explaining how you can get
even more abstract with your grid area
names notice how he's using shapes to
define the grid areas making it
extremely clear which part of the UI
each grid area is for now once you have
your grid template areas defined you can
set some sizing for the rows and columns
in this example the grid container has a
fixed height so we'll have each
individual row take up exactly 25% of
the height using the repeat function
when it comes to our columns will give
the first column a fixed width the two
middle columns
auto property to automatically resize
based on the viewport and then the last
column a fixed width also 240 then the
next step is to place the children in
their appropriate grid area now because
I have all the children laid out in a
logical order I'm going to use enth
child to select them but you could
definitely use your own custom class
names here as well the important thing
to notice is that we're applying grid
area a to this element no matter where
it sits in the container it will take up
that grid template area you defined
above now we'll repeat this process for
every single area in the grid the end
result is this grid with all the
children in the appropriate spots and
now how do we impress our friends with
this fancy staggered intro animation
well the first thing I'm going to do is
set up a variable for the staggered
delay this will allow us to change the
timing without having to manually update
the delay for all thirteen elements next
we're going to need a keyframes
animation if you're not familiar with
keyframes they basically allow you to
move from one set of properties to
another from as the starting point to is
the ending point we want to start with
an opacity of zero or invisible a scale
of zero point three and then we'll also
rotate the color by a hundred and eighty
degrees that's how I create that
rainbow-like color change when the items
are animated in when the animation is
complete the opacity should be 1 the
scale should be 1 and the heat rotate
should be 0 now CSS will automatically
interpolate between the starting and
ending values based on the amount of
time that we specify for the animation
we can apply this animation to all the
cards by setting it as the animation
name then we'll also give it a duration
of 700 milliseconds and a timing
function of ease out now one last
important point here is that we also
need to set the animation film mode to
backwards this will set the elements to
their first keyframe value which in our
case will be invisible otherwise the
cards would be visible before the
animation starts and that just wouldn't
look right at all that takes care of the
animation but now we want to stagger it
and we can do that by setting an
animation delay on each individual
element but we want to do this in a
smart way so if we decide to change the
delay we don't have to update all 13
items to help us I'm going to use the
CSS calc function it can perform basic
calculations on numeric values for the
first item we'll say 1 times the stagger
delay for the second item we'll say 2
times the stagger delay and we'll keep
increasing that for all 13 items and
there's still obviously a lot of code
duplicate
here but you could make this much more
efficient by using something like SAS
where you can run a programmatic for
loop and that's basically all there is
to it we now have this unique animated
grid without any JavaScript or external
CSS framework I'm gonna go ahead and
wrap things up there if this video
helped you please like and subscribe and
make sure to grab the full source code
on fire ship IO thanks for watching and
I will see you in the next one
[Music]